4 l'année la plus importante le guide de
la famille parfaite est une comédie
dramatique sur les hauts et les bas de
la parentalité à une époque du père
performance bon c'est peut-être la chose
la plus autobiographique que j'ai fait
depuis le début de ma carrière il faut
que loaded aussi louis morissette
interprète un père qui a de grandes
ambitions pour sa fille pour qu'elle
soit presque parfaite
inévitablement il ya des tensions excusé
le maire
comment se moque la dépression la de 16
à bas prix c'est grand c'est
l'inspiration de de son cheminement de
mon cheminement de notre relation qui
est vraiment amener un autre niveau là
on n'a pas eu tous ces problèmes là mais
c'est des discussions là dedans qui se
sont retrouvés autour de la table chez
les mauriciens à nantes un examen de
science étant donné que la famille
parfaite n'existe pas le château de
cartes fini par s'écrouler dans le guide
de la famille parfaite
le réalisateur ricardo trogi a dû y
aller dans la nuance
cette fois ci j'ai eu un peu plus que
d'habitude
l'aspect de remettre séquence coupe
j'étais moi-même victime père de famille
a qu'une jeune fille eut aussi à peu
près de l'âge fait que plus sensibles au
sujet soirée de bonheur
une des belles phrases du film est la
suivante et je cite c'est lorsque tu as
des enfants que tu commences à avoir
peur
une phrase qui a interpellé une mère
dans le film est dans la vraie dit je
suis maman nouvellement 27 fait de cinq
mois et donc en revoyant le film là
c'est sûr que c'est cheap avec ce qui se
passe c'est sûr tu es bon là je ne peux
révéler punch mais mais mais oui les
vannes se sont ouvertes là je me suis
dans mon rôle de mère des femmes aussi
je trouve ça tout le match même en effet
même si l'euro deux parents n'est pas de
tout repos
louis morissette ne l'échangerait pour
rien au monde oui c'est des soucis en
même temps
une grande chance d'avoir des enfants me
semble ça fait de moi un bain meilleure
personne pour parce que tout était reçu
des claques il faut préparer le guide de
la famille parfaite prendra l'affiché le
14 juillet ici louis fait depuis mai
fera du canada n'ont rien à côté de ce
que j'ai connu le petit lac en alliés de
la tête leur faisant faveur jeune homme
est pas des grands conseils d'éducation